こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
おい
ペヤングさん
なんでや
何でまた出しとるんやペヤングさん
ファイナルと
こちら激辛ペヤングの新作出ました食感
から一味プラスペヤングに焼きそば
[拍手]
だってなんでまた言ったじゃないですか
最後って意味でしたまた出てますちょっと
待ってこの激辛ペヤングシリーズもう代々
続いてきましたもう何個食べたか
覚えてませんもう
辛いの最後ですよと言わんばかりの
ファイナルというやつが出た後にまた
さらに出てるそのもっとやばそう1位入っ
ちゃってますからねこれ多分ごく激辛より
やばいと思うんすよ僕
[音楽]
ありがとうございますペヤングさん
ありがとうございますまた出してください
センキュー
とりあえず作ってみます
[音楽]
本当にやばい本当にやばい本当にやばい
本当にやばい本当にやばい
[音楽]
あ待って色やばいってちょっと待って
ふりかけじゃねえだろやばいってふりかけ
じゃないやんけ
[音楽]
まあとりあえずどんなもんなのかしっかり
食べてみたいと思いますいただきます
[音楽]
よもう汗でさせてくださいこれもってなる
んですよ皆さんご存知の通り僕辛いでマジ
で無理で
涙出てきた
[音楽]
あの前回食べた激辛ファイナルももう無理
で途中でギブしたのからもう食べれるわけ
がないんですよわかりますもうこの汗の量
で本当に無理なんですよ
[音楽]
新作の獄激辛ペヤングの中身を普通の
ペヤングの中身に変えて後輩の前で俺が
食べていたら俺の超一流のリアクションに
より本当にごく激辛食べてるように見える
んじゃないか鉄
これなら僕でもできるこの
汗の量と過去の動画見てもらったら分かる
と思うんですけども本当に激辛が無理で
絶対無理なんですね感触がもう前の商品の
時点でこれは必ず誰かに食わせるとして今
から後輩を呼んで俺からこれを食べるのを
見せるっていう動画を撮りますですがこの
中身まあ一味ぐらいなら載せといていい
でしょうソースの色あんまり変わらないと
思うんですよ正直
わかんないでしょこれがどんな色してるの
か初見だともう俺リアクションは王じゃ
ないですか正直YouTuberは切って
のリアクションなのでこれの中身のソース
が普通のおいしいペヤングになっていても
ごく激辛食べてるぐらいのリアクション
なら僕できると思うのであたかも普通の
ペヤングなのにごく激辛を完食してるよう
に今から見せてみたいと思いますでは作っ
ていきましょう
まずシンプルに普通の方開けるわ
おーこのソースがいいんですよ本当に味の
感想忘れてたんですけども
前回と僕は変化わからなかったですもう
途中から辛いと痛いしかも記憶になくて
ただなんかやっぱ速乾って書いてるから
アジアで安かったのかな
めっちゃしびれるような辛さでした
僕には無理です普通のペヤングのソースを
準備しましたでこっち開けますこれがマジ
で事の発端なのでこれを取ってで一味の
火薬ぐらいなら多分あった方がいいと思う
のでこれを使いますんで周りにこれが落ち
てればはじめさんごく激辛食べるんだって
思うでしょうさすがにじゃ作っていきます
水切ってきましたはい開けて普通の
ペヤングのソース入れますよしよしよし
よしよしよしよしよしこれで
これでまあいけるでしょう
[音楽]
これさ辛くなったりしないよねこれで
かなり近いでしょさすがにこの赤い一面が
ないと怪しまれるここ大事です多分はい
完成しましたこれ置いてやれば誰がどう見
てもごく激辛ペヤングの新作食べれるよう
にしか見えないけど普通のペヤングです
初めて完成しましたいやまあまあまあまあ
激辛ペヤングて赤いイメージありますけど
も新作なので色はそんなに言及されないと
思うんだよな研究されるかなちょっと怖い
わさっきのふりかけだけかけとくかなんか
こんなふりかけごときで絶対変わんない
でしょ味はやばいけどこれでどう見ても
激辛でしょうえ辛くなんないよね大丈夫だ
よ色的にかなりもう激辛ペヤングに近く
なったちょっと食べてみていいそもそも
辛かったら演技もクソもないんだけど
[音楽]
好きな人もいるから多分作ってられてるん
でしょうけど早速俺の演技力楽しんでて
くださいではターゲット呼びましょう
[音楽]
あこっちこっちこっち
激辛の新作です
見てみて食べるマイクで
食べてないの
嘘でしょ
ちょっとちょっと見届け人として食べる
とこ見せたいなと思って
今回一味プラスらしいです
いただきます
いきますね
あーやばいマジやばいやばい無理無理無理
無理
本当に食べるマンかっていうくらいすごい
よ
いただきます
[音楽]
[拍手]
[笑い]
[音楽]
やばいやばいやばいやばい
汗が
やばい目痛い
目で
助けて
[音楽]
[笑い]
やばいやばい
やばいやばいやばいもうちょっと待って
本当にやばい
そうなるよね
[音楽]
うんうんうんうんうんうんうんうんうん
うんうん
ああこれ
健介とりあえず戻ってきていいよ
[音楽]
やばいやばいやばい
ありがとうありがとうありがとうやばい
頑張ったありがとうございます
感じてほしいこと漢字をちょっとだけ
ちょっとだけ
ちょっとでいいか
喋れない
いただきます
うん
[音楽]
1本多分ある気がする
ない
[音楽]
結構スピード勝負だと思う
[拍手]
明日絶対お腹痛いねこれ
行きます
いやマジであと二口
食べちゃう
頑張れ頑張れ
気持ち気持ち
いいねいいね
[拍手]
ここで渡す
[音楽]
[拍手]
辛くなくないこれ
[音楽]
辛くないね